I just want to thank everybody for
correcting my I said it was Harriet
Beatrice no I - always says you and your
boy I wrote this though but I will
always say snow I know I've done that
from day one but thank you everybody for
correcting me and I should know better
and I didn't even know I said snow how
about that yeah I didn't know I said
that and I was like what yeah you did I
said it more than once you did that's
how you know you Harriet Beecher Stowe
our listeners are going yes of course
you know you don't call somebody
nobody's nobody's last name is snow do
you know anybody's last name but of
course I said it JT snow this is love
with angels and I was gonna say my
favorite baseball player on the angels
back in the day with JT snow yeah and
that's why I've always confused JT snow
because he was built like Harriet
Beecher Stowe cuz he had big hips if you
remember dude I think you the dick dr.
Moe should start podcast together and
you talk about JT snow you know what in
dicks um that would be a good idea yeah
I'd be sick man it says conversation
about baseball players back in the day
and dicks and they're dead and their
dogs and their dong dong don't you dude
what are you up to I'm I'm shooting all
day every day I'm waking today I went up
too early you're an early riser
I'm a pop-pop II can't stand waking up
early never have been able to I love it
it's always tough for me I got a I got a
play tricks on my brother 5:00 a.m. guy
you are hung up and you can work out in
the morning yeah papi doesn't get going
until it's always been this way
well the people huh baby papi it's just
no puffy because I you know I have a
Latin Flair that's what I'm looking at I
think Latin by the way yesterday I was
playing soccer with the dads versus
might the sons my son was there and the
whole time I send in my husband
buzz the buzz the vote for me for me put
me my friend on idea look bus yeah I'll
give it a ball up and I was doing that I
was just so into it first of all the
other guys like what actions are like I
don't know my friend but I'm not from
this country you know but I just played
only play come on let's go everybody
over there my father my [ __ ] son was
like dad stop doing that you're
embarrassing me who are you I don't even
know this kid who is this Gator I was
little whiter I didn't give up on it be
my voice okay little store because I was
screaming the whole time and
hey how about this some of the dad's
competitive
your plan year olds bro everybody yeah
one guy was like taking it down the
field huh I'm like bro bro let the kids
steal the ball from you right [ __ ]
now oh no I was like what are you doing
scoring scoring on the kid I'm like - I
was I went to parent-teacher conference
where all the you know everyone has the
son same age or daughter same age yeah
then all the debt all the family get it
together and then the joy is the one dad
I mean what's cooler than the one dad's
like yeah we got to do dinner all of us
got our dinner like yeah that sounds
good dude I'm forced to be here right
now we're not hanging out at your shirt
our throwback no I know
now did Reggie throw back bro no I know
did that shirt come with a polo pony
that's my question with a pony like
ponytail a polo pony that's a polo shirt
polo pony that's a polo pony shirt bring
up polo and you'll see that they all
wear those shirt this reminds me of like
polos no joke which reminds me of
Versace 80s Miami Beach South Beach just
jacking people off
well the Polo they wear shirts like that
there you go see that's kind of a polo
shirt leave the squad there yeah polos
no joke I've always had a problem with
polo for two reasons there are two girls
I dated very seriously and liked very
much and their boyfriends before me were
polo players now rich [ __ ] I was gonna
say why are they pulling players because
they had the kind of money they had the
kind of money where they owned a fleet
of polo ponies and I said something to
the effect of how about this my
girlfriend she's Eddie he's just such an
aggressive guy he was just like kind of
owned me and I go well if he tried that
[ __ ] around me I'd beat his [ __ ] ass
and she goes you wouldn't Brian he would
kill you
excuse me so me super rich and super
athletic and so much bigger than you and
really muscular and I go I was like I I
had to take a breather and I had to
remind myself that I'm a [ __ ] that
I'm a like I'm I'm an actor I had to
take a minute because I was about to go
I'll stay off by heal up right now
hoarse I won't and I'm courting subdue
I'll [ __ ] you up right now I know you
know what I did III got a description of
him I found out
and she was right how rich she was and I
went sometimes you get out outfit and
this is a case where I've been out alpha
so that does she run off with her again
no she's worse for that and he broke up
with her so she was clearly still hung
up on can I be honest I've never met
anyone in my entire 35 years on this
planet so rare never everyone because
you have to be in the circles I grew up
in Denver's never I've never I've never
seen a ring that guy I've been around it
that's the best polo player in the world
take a look at what he looks like I
wonder if he's guy aid yeah that guy
what does he get laid um yeah it's big
outside of the Argentina Argentina but
it's big into very wealthy circles you
you have to be super rich he's alright
he's very average mm-hmm guess he rides
horses though cuz here's better when
you're on a horse relax man it's just a
man on a horse you ever heard that
expression relax man it's just a man on
a horse that's really a picture of that
guy
yeah polos kind of it has to be a dying
sport especially the younger demo I
don't think it's dying among niche
something among the rich right so I bet
eventually does because the rich are
young you know and they pass on their
kids but kids are like what the [ __ ] is
this like golf you know golf is dying
like a [ __ ] is it no no I don't
believe I don't believe Oh weird I just
read this whole article on all top golf
more golf clothes more golf courses that
I had opened but golf in general from
1830 is dead dad I know are you [ __ ]
me
this is UB no it's a great sport though
I mean in other words did you being
silly no I didn't know that I really owe
ya but before young kids yeah not the
amount of time it takes time there's a
spike when Tiger Woods playing cuz it
made kind of cool on that you got a
dedicate how many hours how many hours
the decline of golf to an eighteen and I
just read this water you got drought so
they can't keep it probably really
expand on that it's like what it's the
it obviously they're closing because the
drought stuff like that but not as many
people are playing like it every year
it's going down down down down you know
what's going up top golf up up and up
why because right you don't have to
dedicate
seven hours is [ __ ] game and it's
also a game you don't have to know game
it well golf I guess below memory
retired man it's older yeah but now even
you know the younger demographic it's
not interested in it mmm very much time
you have to you have to dedicate it I
polo will always be at such a rough
sport it's such a crazy rough people die
you know so I think it'll always be kind
of it's always been a very small niche
sport anyway it's always been you can't
afford think about if you have eight you
have to have like I think it's something
like six polo ponies but even football
is on the decline it's because people
are worried about CT and head trauma
feel popular football is now think about
golf yeah if footballs on the decline
Golf sure as [ __ ] is on them your son
speaking of which I saw a picture of
your son next to all the other children
and he looks like he could fit all the
children in his body he could just bear
hug him all night literally looks like
Andre the Giant car no children he's a
big boy I mean I'm hoping he's not the
real a football when he can run through
everybody probably you have to write if
he's that talented yeah I got a Stanford
get your education look it is yeah yeah
if he's just big and gifted right yeah
you look uh would you cook on here chin
the decline of golf in 2018 yeah I read
this whole thing and so I was get my
hair cut you're staying they have I
think it's called entrepreneur and it's
about top golf but they're saying how
golf around the world is on the decline
in the around the world around and
they're trying to figure it out yeah
like what the [ __ ] and you know it's a
long game and so they this huge investor
these two British twins they're twins
wanted to do top golf their idea was how
can we make golf fun the fun but in that
not everyone has to be good at because
seem out golf to get good you have to
date dedicates so much [ __ ] time to
it and no one you have so much going on
oh so these two twins in Britain there
you go that's exactly what I read they
decide to make a game so not small holes
big holes where if you hit it you get
points there's there's food there's
beverages like a VIP lounge and you just
play that no I think they do right no
there's what's that one Torrance and
they're having some problems going on
with [ __ ] but there's one is in Vegas
but it should come in LA have you ever
been on top golf now they're amazing
fighter one two and in air
oh yeah we both know huh yeah that's
right pressure to win probably well
we're in Vegas I put together doing a
show in what is that I don't know we
haven't well this is announcing but
we'll have info soon but when we go
we'll go that will fly in early I don't
go there but yeah they talk about how
tough these two twin these British dudes
present it because they need investors
and all these newer older white
investors like golf [ __ ] no like that's
a dying breed Annelle no like no hear us
out man we're gonna flip it on its head
with this what we're gonna do
and now crushing now topped well no one
would touch them like Titleist name any
big golf sponsor would not pong ping and
pong or the [ __ ] dog would not touch
them because they're like you guys are
doing something so different but now
everyone's on board
Wow everybody it's a great story man
read that article top golf yeah it's
really really read a lot of it it sounds
like a blast in this magazine to this
entrepreneur to dope because they're
talking about the hundred best companies
to work for and what they do and a lot
of these companies most of them were in
Silicon Valley somewhere in Utah they're
like one or two now is a silicon - its
silicon silicon something of silicon the
same thing I know you think crazy look
on but what the day but they were saying
how these companies do like this company
doesn't have vacation time and that was
the headline I'm like ow [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] up I won't want to work there
what are you Apple and China like people
jumped off the roof right no what they
have is if you want to work from home
what you want to do as long as you get
your work done they want quality work so
I need the work done you do whatever you
want as long as it skin done
they found that to be the case they
found that when people are happy they
are more productive that than my
favorite one of my favorite [ __ ]
sayings of all time is like in this book
called why nations fail it's a classic
about like they look at why some nations
are really successful and why others are
and they compare like and they talk
about institutions and all that seven
hours you have to have incorruptible
institutions but one of things is that
in a society where your work gets you
benefits so so when you work in a
company like Apple or whatever it's not
in China but Starbucks where it is and
you are actually happy in the
environment it's clean it's safe you
have friends and you have time to
yourself right you're just more
productive and there's this amazing
saying
that I think was Daron Acemoglu this guy
was at Harvard you know whatever and he
said you can hold a gun so so if you
look at like countries that have like
authoritarian leaders they don't really
produce a lot like like Russia's main
you know source of income as oil and
some minerals but they don't produce
those last time you bought a Russian
computer Russian car oh wait you know
tell me so
why well this is great saying you can
hold a gun to a man's head and make him
pick up a box or move a stone from one
point to another but you can't hold a
gun to a man's head and make him have a
great idea in other words you know the
only reinforces no the only way you
create you after with the way you foster
creativity is with a happy workforce
which is why everyone here only works
twice a week that's right that's right
and you get a pension every week just
been on horse
excuse me horse horse horse black man
for audiences and you meant hoary and
barbecue you meant horse
nope I mean the women who will suck your
dick for money Brian Brendan I don't
know where to go with that happy
employee leo happy tune it's like I
don't have Lucy so I've had a [ __ ]
every Friday I send a girl to his house
you too yeah you know I don't really get
the statement no it's really nice yeah
guys
gentlemen I do know a Conda who knows
Dave yeah Tyrone I know a guy who works
for a very very wealthy man and this guy
is a guy who was like I've never been
with a prostitute I never would and this
guy who he and his buddies who owned
this very very successful company
company well anyway let's just say the
company called firing the kid he now
sits at a rock band I said oh oh really
you think you wouldn't huh and he said
this is from his mouth he goes no it's
just against my principles I wouldn't do
it and they went oh cool all right well
let's let wanna bet my buddy goes I'm
telling you bro telling you you know
it's just that nothing I would do and he
had a girl and well he got a knock on
his door on his hotel door and it was
about 10:00 p.m. and he said he opened
the door is a Ferrari and he said dude
you
[ __ ] he said I he goes I I just had
to let her in Englewood you don't have
this yet well [ __ ] brains out all night
because the anybody goes you have no
idea what five thousand dollars we need
was you cost $5,000 a night when you
think because well a lot of times when
from what I hear yeah when you think
prostitutes Oh what I'm thinking of like
walking the streets I kind of busted one
[ __ ] broken heel
oh man no no no when you spend five
straight on 18 there are those women
were five some girls yeah and then there
then there's the next pair for that yeah
oh man yeah then there's the next level
right so there's the Instagram girls all
body and then there's those there's
those girls that you see in those Calvin
Klein ads that you know the Victoria's
Secret touch juror you like what
everyone got bills okay
who's paid yes I am cute Oh what are
these you know uh oh yeah so I'm not
trouble I I do not mean either what not
up in here may not up in my hard-earned
money you can get my heart or not for
John dick jokes yeah you want to suck my
dick for money nah [ __ ] crazy girl who
else somebody else paid the bill well I
didn't do it for free instead of my room
look somebody huh yeah yeah man I gotta
sleep sleep you know well you're up at
5:00 don't [ __ ] my sleep button I'm up
at 5:30 with my show and I'm not gonna
compromise my shots because some twelve
my happiness and a 12 knocks on the door
trying to [ __ ] up my sleeve my routine
no way good bring it somewhere else
I'll say you better go next door [ __ ]
yeah you better get it going next door
to Brendan maybe he's around I don't
know I'm gonna go next door after you
finish with me to Brian
[Laughter]
yeah there it is buddy
there it is young fun shooting yeah I
really hello I'm working with you shoot
all year long I'm wearing with some
Townsend
how long do you uh I should tell January
25th and I'm done
so yeah rest of November yeah yep
December and January
um well November's not in that chunk of
time sir
what do you mean November I'm sorry
November I'll [ __ ] bro November December
you don't win you're JH let's try to
correct you I thought March November due
December than January till for seven
months and then uh and then hopefully it
airs and gets picked back up and they do
it all over again free many many yes you
had an experience interesting experience
I'm doing the scene with these two guys
who are playing high school students
even though they're twenty their
twenties and they're both so good and
I'm a little one kid he had like three
lines and I was like guys [ __ ] good
and he kept doing it different and he
kept taking subtle directly you know
dealing the good actors when the
director goes can you give it a little
bit more like the more of a question
mark and he does it perfectly like just
that playing an instrument my planet
that subtle instrument because I was
like the [ __ ] is this guy man he's
[ __ ] good and I go you're good and he
goes oh thank you so much knock out some
nice to hear thank you alright yeah yeah
yeah then I found out he's the lead in
Book of Mormon on Broadway for three
years she's yeah I'm like oh like oh
thank you yeah okay yeah yeah his name
is Gabe great kid but like just so good
so [ __ ] dude I'm going to your old
stomping grounds Book of Mormon just
remind me of Broadway I'm out there end
of November but I'm going early cuz I do
press for Showtime because I'm missing
the fury Wilder fight so that Thursday
and Friday I'm [ __ ] so much press for
them but anyways at anyway at night I'll
be able to maybe see some shows that I'm
that Bruce Springsteen a couple of
recommendations for you from Jimmy Burke
who's usually up on all that's right um
speaking of fights I can't wait for the
Dante Walter not to bother yeah we can't
wait for that fights number first there
is a room or at least if you listen to
Instagram or Donald Cerrone that he
might fight Conor McGregor that would be
exciting
putting the money on Donald to fight for
Donald bull
good fight good fight great fight fight
the bat money on it yeah from my sources
yeah I think it's happening yeah just
gotta wait for counter sign the contract
I believe Donald deserves that and I'd
be really excited to see that it's a
smart move man it's such a smart move
cuz for cowboy he's the most winningest
fighter of all time he's very very
recognizable he's coming off a huge win
yeah it's [ __ ] dollar oniy once come
down 55 for Connor you got a guy who
will play the game with you he's gonna
he's gonna strike with you
you're also finding the witness UFC
fighter of all time Cowboys a big name
it's not an impossible match up for
Conor khabib there can be a tough
matchup for me so Connor needs to get a
win so I would imagine I don't know but
the odds would might be in Connors
favorite he might be the favorite here
slightly I would have Matt I don't know
it's a it's not a easy fight for Connor
or cowboy now but it's easier than say
Tony Ferguson or Habib and it's a huge
name and Connor has to get a win to get
back to a title shot so that I it makes
all the sense in the world because you
if you're Connor this is what I do I and
let's say he wins these I go yet the
last we can lose but I go
Connor cowboy huge payday then he gets
tile shot Connor winner if khabib Tony
Ferguson and then whatever happens there
then you get Nate Diaz 155 right you say
this is for Connor this Connor is the
next three fights I go cowboy winner of
Tony Habib and then Nate Diaz and round
what if he gets beat up by cowboy I said
only if we win right so what happens
then for Connor and Nate Diaz off rides
off the sunset and that's it that's it
you you won't you won't ever get to
Kabira Tony if he loses the cowboy yeah
tough fight man to fight for but that's
every fight stuff for these guys at this
level right I mean there's yeah but for
you know for for Conor it's just like
you know he's been fighting just animals
monsters and bad match he wins you know
most of them but then you got a win one
man yeah you know I'm saying that there
I thought was gonna be either anti
Pettis cowboy
you
I thought maybe Pettis but they're doing
Pettis again someone else that cry I
thought that thing that Yair Rodriguez
who apparently was sick all the way up
until the fight from what cording to
Donald but that that move I've never
seen anything like that
what is that double it wasn't it was I
know where he ducked yeah it was a you
slip and then he ducked like what how do
you even think that would work I was
like you said tom was the end up before
you said it wasn't an accident here
dunno what's so silly when people say
weird move not really so you go under
knocks him out by accident
I don't know he landed in the second
round Cowboys done it [ __ ] I don't know
years ago they say that's how the cowboy
cups Watson can pull that off what those
guys do that Wow yeah Rodriguez is a
freak man freak he's so athletic so
athletic
remember they gonna cut them like come
on no man that guy's so exciting to
watch really exciting to watch at 45 too
tall for a 45 oh yeah all those 45 it's
45 s get nasty it's nasty poor Korean
zombie dude I was watching maybe you
know this lady uh this is that so racist
you don't maybe know of her maybe you
both do maybe I know her she's in the
meg she's a Korean actor but she is good
good gorgeous in the meg now real quick
the meg is a shark movie I don't say
it's the worst but it's not good oh yeah
but it is entertaining but it it can't
hold a [ __ ] candle to the shallows
with Blake Lively or to Java so good it
had them for the NRA's ending of all
time it was still cool though it was
truly the most went down yeah we'll take
all that out before it's legit as [ __ ]
yeah I think best shark movie vault it
was terrible for is so good but the Meg
not so much yes but this little diamond
I'm here all the way she's called Rita
Chinese Chinese yeah Pauly Bing Bing
looks like it's very good-looking Korean
girls I like my girl goes game she's
gorgeous summit yeah she's Korean for
sure psy kpop are not capable I came
this type of Korean and she's super
famous kind of beautiful actress yeah
she's super famous I heard about some
gorgeous
some Chinese actress that disappeared
because of the Chinese government
authorized it's the same name
she ran into tax drop her name's Lee
Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing
Bing Bing Bing how many fathers she have
on this game she likes her famous cuz
there's a girl in this in the movie
who's so distracting who I thought was a
terrible casting and she's so famous
that no idea four and forty five
thousand all right so she's still flying
under the radar that's okay that's a ton
dude if you're China if you're China
[ __ ] big movie star like go to the go
to the actors in in the meg I'll see
Jason Statham is the big one but there's
no girl in this movie who's so
distracting she doesn't it doesn't make
any sense she's casted in the movie and
are here acting she she looks like her
here's is like she's [ __ ] Laura Croft
in an animated movie she's a lesbian but
she's pretty smooth oh yes you ever
heard of Ruby Rose I sure haven't
me neither what you've never heard of
her she was like everybody famous yeah
because I was got a clown on her to my
girl and I'm like look her up in Nasik
oh yeah yeah well known she she was uh
she's the next Catwoman to thirteen
point three million thirteen point three
million dollars that Vin Diesel movie to
she's a beautiful woman she's like she's
pretty she's gay she'll suck your
titties look at her she's gorgeous she's
cool look yeah she energy cool again in
the movie it's distracting because she's
just so she's supposed to be like the
the doctor I'm uh saying doctors can't
be hobby supposed to be like the the
brains behind the whole operation and
her hair and it is it's strange though
yeah it's ice in her hair so distracting
what Taylor I've never heard she's she's
gorgeous
I she's very pretty purchase yeah I read
a thing a pillow Swift looks like a
goddamn sharp a next door right there
yeah Ruby Rose what a great name to look
at our face I know I didn't she's her
face is strikingly good-looking yeah
I've never heard of her I like her short
hair and a tats man that's her on the
set of Meg over to the right they are
right to her here there sir here that's
her here's like that the entire [ __ ]
movie like your animation it drove me
nuts
well that's a problem really that's
right here the whole the whole movie why
they just made it look like upset at
things why is her hair like that I have
no idea
that's a dumb choice if you thought the
shallows was preposterous watch that
movie you're like what the [ __ ] Gordon
they're dead shark does everything but
fly through the air
this one also flies to the a splash
there this is like a kung fu movie it's
wet sigh come on man it's so ridiculous
you know it was entertaining though we
need another good kung-fu movie like
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon the last
good kung that's her yeah yeah I heard
in that movie that no that's not as she
smoked show there who's her a girl she
don't like dudes at all huh this large
thing I know I'm like it hurts my
feelings a little bit that she doesn't
like to I'm like good for her I know
I've never heard of her Jess you got you
butt chin yeah of course man when she
first stepped on to the scene she was
every girl's girl crush like that's the
reason why I trying to have a crush on
her now even though I have no shot wow
that's really long here hmm keep the
short hair yeah take her more seriously
I think she went viral cuz she did a
video where she was wearing like this
blonde wig and looked like a girly girl
and then she took it all off and looked
really like butch like yeah androgynous
like butch I'm a steal your girl type of
thing do you find her attractive cat
I think she's attractive are you
attracted to girls at all kind of
visually yeah but you can appreciate it
yes I can appreciate it good looking -
yeah like visually not a sex addict that
girl come on too much bro she's cute I
like hey come on now for Ruby Rose where
we work that's like driving if that'd be
like find out Ruby Rose drives a [ __ ]
Dodge Neon
damn damn Ewok huh mmm those two I
didn't know damn him I didn't know oh
yeah she's bi
Brenda take it easy bro that's why
please Sun God take it easy problem sing
to me every morning [ __ ] says that's
she's right in your wheelhouse right in
your wheel I not heard a wheel of cheese
ah cheese and demi god damn seeing but
yeah hey I've brenda was up at my place
and I pulled out some cheese because I
can't eat cheese this early in the
morning
no way but it's cheese amigos I'll have
a piece diagnosis cheese so I'm usually
in you guys know I can't eat you know
I mean leave it out no it was nice dude
you got to eat some cheese dude it was
nice dude I burned a thousand calories
this morning right Ryan my peloton bike
damn thousand calories and God dog she
didn't hang out there - oh hey
hard-earned man law you find the wall to
watch those - my bump suck each other's
titties
well I jack off in the corner I'm
talking making it poor you're making a
noise if bro hard-earned in the corner
it's so dead presidents watching are you
standing both are terrible whatever they
want
I do get on a need like cauliflower got
jack jacking and while they're trying to
get it on also don't say sucking each
other's titties you don't even know what
they're doing it's not like they're
going yeah they do they say I don't know
what they do but you're amazing and get
out of the corner in their apartment no
well I'm paying hard-earned money man
they're not gonna they have enough money
you're not gonna give them like you know
that 27 dollars in your pocket to stand
in the corner you ain't call Z you've
seen Halsey you ever heard her sing no I
lose all it you know heard Halsey sing
and she's single now brother you're out
of your body dude she first of all she's
a 210 just think that her voice is a
[ __ ] from the heavens chin you're a
hater on voices what do you think of her
I don't know if I heard her sing oh
let's see can't down there the cover
which one you want to do the Halsey
can't sing no no he clicked back hatin
that's like her at her worst moment
that's like Brian towns not funny you're
trying a new joke or we can play Brian
towns Beth
you tell me she gets sing and suck this
dick bro all the times that you rain on
my parade to the super like all the
clubs you get a smoky voice bro you
think you broke my heart oh girl for
goodness sake you think I'm crying oh my
ohhh well I ain't
it's a Bieber song neither one of them
wrote it yeah it's so interesting how
she's got a great voice but it's how
African American influence on all white
singers is so incredibly powerful she's
black
whoo Halsey format is black she's
certain dad's black yeah don't go to
another one chins that true yeah I
didn't know that once white blood Wow
where's because she has her this one
without me um I don't know her big song
I guess play that she's got that love is
her looser was like that big but this is
more of a live thing go to that bad at
love one always below but she's like ow
I'm you can play she trying to explain
where I scroll to the path so just so
Brian can feel her out no I like is that
the full video rest
Lucy I love that Halsey singing
blink-182 but that's pretty cool well he
said he saw it there right no no you're
just on it chin if you wait tell me what
to do about cat take it
[Music]
so the actual video yeah yeah might as
well just 184 million be views good I
don't know her voice is so unique I feel
like her dad's black she's white as [ __ ]
but dad is why yeah so she's a porter
yes your dad but I think she's talented
and beautiful oh for sure right
yeah good for her palsy parents oh [ __ ]
her dad look at that black that's cool
yeah ever dad looks like her dad looks
like generally chancellor rapper but
goofier yeah mm-hmm-hmm dan that's not
easy
crazy-cool no I get her to the left
there be I mean I love you I love those
cornrows yeah I really do daddy she's a
smoke show I know how he got thrown that
you're talking about my girls hmm weird
yeah weird yes she's a dime pop singer
housing really as a black girl yeah
she's dating G easy
that's them there they broke up I gotta
change my name they broke if I was a
rapper what would I be called maybe
white dick lips McGee medium white
medium or sticky lips mister sticky lips
thin thin lip in the no Spotty's body my
red spot what mine bit what's my so your
spotty what if I'm you got it you call
me Pete you call me peanut butter now
even cookies big give me BB BB sweet big
big brown peanut butter
big brown pbbbb tasty okay thick thick
thick thick my yeah yeah Vicky brown
tasty brown and tasty know what bro
Brown know our band was McCoys the brown
no thick in the spots Twizy brown no
thick and the squeezy Brown in the end
of spots thick in the spots featuring
Twizy brown and the spots y'all what
yeah
please don't turn a might no turn turn a
Bobby volume up in the speaker in the
headphone y'all
like turn the volume on why are you
talking like that ah ah no all right
we're going new Whole Foods gonna get my
tuna arm and some sweet potatoes I'm on
a restricted diet y'all say goodbye to
psoriasis
you can [ __ ] join in ready no I don't
want to leave me hanging thick you don't
want no no no what no no Twizy what does
it make you be tasty twiddle Vicky P
Twizy Brown P G B yo yo yo thank you
baby
Thank You B they get be in the spot big
gay all up in the Twizy thick twisty
think knob big gay all up and the booze
you got you guys want to do like the
lilz are young I'll be a little thick
you always take big gay little spot a
little little thick in a little spot big
spot now I want little D thanks you're
like Twitter so I want to call you twizz
ly well I liked red vines better twist
tasty no I like red twist tasty it's
pretty [ __ ] good whoo Stacey's Yahoo
is tasty twist AC and they and the spy
how about little cookies potty owl a
little crooked teeth but I don't has a
ring to it little crooked teeth I have
crooked teeth no yo yo little crooked
teeth I said I don't have cook my you
know like that
no there's RIT that kind of they're not
crooked enough that the Invisalign work
so let's call it worked
Oh yo little wrinkle twist a little
wrinkle face it's little wrinkle face up
in here y'all
little wrinkle face now you got a couple
little wrinkles up in this [ __ ] red
wrinkles red wrinkle fits its
grandfather clock yo that wrinkled face
no it's droopy balls this long ball quit
Stacy and red wrinkled face aka aka low
balls a K the chrome feat the crow's
feet
aka prune balls ache a leather face ache
a little crooked teeth cafe k spots on
spots on spot yeah it's just me with
eyes you always the catcher's mitt with
eyes aka okay old gym bag faith Oh a
Chin's thing there be I guess y'all get
this mother
some cream get this [ __ ] all the
face cream before we started yeah oh the
face cream is super offensive I got
wrinkles y'all not read don't rap did
scaly skin
please don't rap dude dude you know what
I am going to change subject sir say
stop rapping in a black tone um you know
what I am gonna do you guys how I
frickin uh I do that palette on bike all
the time yeah it's doing every morning
to send the house dev a treadmill now Oh
which could be dope although my knees a
little sketchy but um my knees super
sketch it's gonna go any day now um
anyways anyway so uh that Pelton
headquarters is in New York and you know
Robin that girl I was talking about all
the time I've talked about it in here a
bunch
she's my digital trainer she doesn't
know it but she's my digital dream she
did repost me today not a big deal but
their headquarters in New York so I'm
gonna go there every morning workout
with the actual [ __ ] team you don't
say that's my plan
yummy head there every morning in New
York and get my actual ride on I just do
it digitally you know I'm saying hey
pellets not maybe you send us a couple
of treadmills I would use a treadmill to
don't really I don't know if you're the
demo but yeah sure well I'm 51 and in
stupid shape nobody might have a heart
attack on that thing and that's
liability she isn't a shape how about
this morning I do her 45-minute hip hop
class and it's going it stopped oh my
God my likes are [ __ ] burning and she
goes
two days ago I ran hundred miles so
let's go let's [ __ ] go and the more
that I worked out six times before this
like the day I should probably go where
that yeah she's a monster oh and she was
a lawyer in Philadelphia before she
sided start doing this such a badass
she's the only one I worked out it not
that she's only when I respect that much
from the guy she can tell me what to do
yeah that's intense he's a fly she went
to in the class there's like eight no no
[ __ ] talking we don't talk in him ago
yeah damn damn I know yeah I don't know
man that's a hard that's a she's a
little thing feisty in and shape as a
[ __ ]
she's got married too mm-hm well well
I'm gonna go then work out work out that
hard all the time and I don't care
enough but I think you'd like that class
though yeah do you like the class we did
at a tart yeah
I loved it the the forum I [ __ ] liked
it you'd like to box and burn one then I
bet I would but that was just plenty for
me that 30-minute yeah I was fine I was
fine with that
Oh pop-pop-pop-pop a thick here once
that like chasing up will you say twist
hey Stacy
yeah alright sure so twist a see what do
ya little wrinkles there's tasty had no
problem no listen little wrinkles my
thing is how I read wrinkle no littering
the read wrinkle setting is not a like
read room cuz I like middle it'll drink
little rink a little rank a little rink
little rink little ring tasty this has
got after taking about 15 minutes before
I start getting my sweat on then at 30
I'm breathing hard and that's when
little little little thick my little
rank little ring was tasting oh let's
ready to go yeah I just started on you
got another 30 minutes in yeah I like an
hour impressive I like an hour dude
you're in shape for a big I need to
freaking yeah one two marathons man I
won't do man you do I'm so itchy reason
II you're you got that little robot
money yeah I just want to [ __ ] do
marathons man I got a bum knee that's
the goal you got a trick knee let me ask
you this with your trick knee have you
have you cuz my knee the other day was
[ __ ] up mmm and I go my knee hurts and
my trainer who's really good goes where
and I go here and he goes okay do me a
favor and he rolled my thigh out a
certain part of it yeah I need was on
who's that yeah yeah well that means you
don't have a knee problem it means it's
just maybe muscle there time Oh a little
rink Nazi little [ __ ] rink a
light-sport first all right 30 years so
my knee has some issues from all the
trauma so when you relate your injuries
to mine it drives me nuts how about so
yeah I know when I say I have an EPROM
yeah I've been telling the listeners for
about six years that have any problem no
I just haven't done anything about it so
when I run so it might be from the years
of football I'm sure your trainer if he
told me the same stretches wouldn't you
ship for me right I hear you
I'm glad it worked for you how about
when I gave you instructions on how to
sprint because you were together the way
rocky does yeah we did and I go you know
when you he goes he ran anyway I didn't
realize he was running like Sylvester
Stallone does in the movie and I went
hey when you run here because I took
sprinting classes when I was in high
school
and I went run like this and does make
you faster right and he goes oh hold on
I'm sorry I because I didn't work with
the best
I didn't play football on a high level
and work with the best [ __ ] coaches
on how to run in the world and I didn't
do that
afterwards either what were you saying
about cuz I wasn't running like
Sylvester on the movie exactly like him
you tell me I shouldn't roll him I was
actually embarrassed we were we got
embarrassed we were filming friend kid
3d running on the beach
yes yeah and I decided to give you a
they did sprint total a snowman and one
see run perfect for him when you're
making a comedy show game a boxing
lesson on set last yesterday and I had
text Brennan just so I wasn't a total
[ __ ] dude how about I sent you the
clip I think we posted two right Katla
the final kid 3d
how long does that same to thank you 3d
so good it was so good it's like the
camera being me too I'm super proud of
it I am so it seems forever ago it's
really a tragedy that we don't do it
again
it really is worst yet uh scroll up it
was a lot of work but it was a lot there
it is far left Brian Brian come on touch
me there Brandon Brandon Brandon get rid
of [ __ ] yourself why would anyone go see
this
say no to draw this always oh my god
that was my funnest day we own it but uh
kids out there on the Internet
and figure out how to get it's so good I
know we don't I think Fox owns it but
remember we look a lot like Judd Apatow
in that shot but the point is damn it
was so fun we were good
I know spent a lot of time just the
three of us made that you mean Mitch
wrote that thing I know it was so good
for the resources we had in the short
amount of time we would sit around like
a month yeah we shot the next day with
ideas it was so good and how fun was it
when someone had a really good we had no
money to do it we did it with zero zero
money how is that possible it's just we
figured it out oh and by the way cuz I
was a [ __ ] I mean a lot of it
didn't work because we just didn't have
the money but it still was great for
what it was turned out really really
good did we beat Amy Schumer and Game of
Thrones on iTunes yeah we did chin I'm
glad you asked
it's not a big deal man it was really
good I feel like we should do something
like that again I know it was so good
I'm working on a little stuff we could
have more yeah but not like that
no that your talk about something
different this time we could bring on
actual riders and I think it's a legit
[ __ ] and sketch show series why you
could do a series like that easily and
sell it it was so good I mean let's not
get carried away but yeah I was cool you
know with a really good winning writer
sitting around you take a piss for a new
current events gonna pee out of your dog
yeah
mommy - security absurd please do okay
please do all right
sometimes ping just feels so nice that
is just yeah I know you mean well let's
tell you pissed your pants bro um a long
time can I be honest because I feel like
I'm in the circle of trust
having the save tree I nobody's
listening no one's listening after we
finished filming on Monday
I was taking a hot piss and didn't get
all of it out and have lift up the old
noggin that happens into my jeans yeah
and I had the biggest piss stain on my
on my pants that's a problem I got my
three wheel [ __ ] Batmobile like an
[ __ ] yeah I've had pretty
embarrassing I've done that before
well I'm like I'm in a rush I'm like
well we're done I had more peeing
shafted yeah well there it is now I'm
all wet and jeans don't drive fast
dammit means take seven hours to cover
it take a long time to come here
[ __ ] you did Ken yes I was a 35 year
old man did that yeah my father was not
these jeans but my dad likes to we used
to fly he had his own like a little
small plant he's a hobby of his and he
said I think you did this we said I got
I got a ping I got a bathroom thing here
I go what do you mean he goes you pee in
this thing and I go well that's not
possible cuz I'm sitting down because
now you do it like this
you ever done it he goes nope I go I'll
be careful because you're flying and
he'd work you know 10,000 feet up in
here and he decided to try to pee and it
didn't work because he had it wrong and
when I tell you that he pissed all over
himself he emptied his bladder laughing
think about sitting down and just
basically peeing against take a I don't
know a cup and just pee against the
other side of it and and it just it just
was the most ridiculous thing I was like
well there it is and he was just covered
in piss I was like enjoy this you ever
piss in a bottle you'd be surprised how
much pee pee you hold it oh dude I fill
the whole [ __ ] tennis I'll fill up
Gatorade things I've done in a while you
piss a lot yeah you have no idea so when
you got you're holding it yeah
fires out like a super soaker yeah does
all right we have some current events
yeah let's do cats first so dave
chappelle photobombs uh a engagement
shoot he was a brewery where a couple
was having some photos taken notice Dave
in the background
asked him if he would take some photos
he said oh no great but then he did this
this is a great that's [ __ ] hilarious
I will die [ __ ] dude that's the best
engagement photo ever hold on the so the
photographer shooting the couples go
ahead Oh Dave Chappelle mm-hmm and one
individual picture of Dave I think he
wanted ya individual photos and then
Dave said no but he ended up talking to
the couple changed his mind and was like
I'm just gonna photo bomb your photos
yeah but he's not gonna let him like
take individuals from great and
afterwards he said to the photographer
we're gonna go viral that's hilarious
dude this is fantastic where's this at
Ohio that's London background i [ __ ]
he seems like a lovely human being dude
here in comedy I do you've never met him
never member I chose that the first time
that had me headline that belly rhymes
yeah for a while such a good dude yeah
he's lost the reason he's so relevant as
he doesn't believe he's better than
anybody still I think he's just a you
know that's a hilarious picture that's
what else you got so a Japanese man
married his um it's the Japanese
equivalent to an Alexa except for it has
a hologram in it where you put up images
of animate women and this is a 16 year
old girl so supposedly in like yep
digital years and he married her they
had a 17 no $14,000 reception with 40
people there there was a cat sized doll
in her place and she didn't want the
hologram there she wears the ring on her
left hand now and his mother did not
come to the wedding for very obvious
reasons you imagine well it's the movie
her but it can be different can you
imagine your son going down a million
hologram I would feel like a complete
complete failure it's just I'm like dude
you [ __ ] me real humans are out
there yeah what's that video dude hold
up school what's that percentage do Jen
I scroll down research found that in
Japan 42 percent of men and 44 percent
of women between ages of 1834 are
virgins
yeah they have a crisis over there right
now which room not yeah nobody's [ __ ]
nobody Sun hides they're focusing too
much on their careers right now why
don't we don't work too hard but we
locked the [ __ ] we're here to drop loads
I'm 51 red ranked little rake little
rake little rinky little sassy little
recently no twists a snow little rink
little thing guys twist AC we set up a
booth I'm here to eat your rolls and get
my dick sucked get with this I don't
want that to be the bar call yeah roll
you just say hey twist day seeing a
little drink here you guys want to play
around we are all yours when I say you
guys I mean to do gals you got you down
you guys but you are a lot of times
you're putting on Japanese men probably
look better as women than do you're
gonna fool us for sure Samoan if
especially I've had a bunch of sakis you
put me in Godzilla outfit I'm getting
weird yeah there are certain like
cultures like Armenian men not fooling
anybody
yeah or Arabic men or they're not gonna
fool anybody trust me it's gonna be
tough to be transgender and be Russian
yeah you know to me even tougher
being transgender being Samoan correct
God answer yeah shoe hose a big taco for
the Cincinnati babies big calves not yet
suck my dick clearly you're a man yeah
that's a big mouth [ __ ] Zanghi from
Russia trying to be a girl like come on
bro can't do it can't deserve anything
you know if transgenders I'm sure
they're oh yeah bro hold on go back to
that article for a minute what's the
video I'd like to see this kid yeah
that's scene IV first of all is anyone
in this room ever heard of any of this
no I'm not familiar people marrying
sergeant gear
well know that oh this is him no it's a
commercial okay so the app basically
texts you throughout the day almost like
like a friend yes I go Bieber yeah this
is the movie her yeah
exactly and apparently uh the company
who married him and the hologram have
married three thousand seven hundred
other people to hologram are you legally
married no I think it's just like the
night [ __ ] thing yeah I think so
the man also said that he does not cheat
on his wife dude people are so lonely
but if this helps I'm all for it if this
house feels so they don't commit suicide
they don't feel like losers let's get
some a nice ass huh
this looks fun can I do like a video
vixen like a blowout [ __ ] ghetto girl
and then we like hanging out and stuff
like this did you have to cook all that
though yeah thank you for living
yeah that's a little but again if he's a
16 year olds and he gets his rocks off
by [ __ ] this hologram dude pump away
I don't know I said hopefully but
[ __ ] pump away bro
instead of doing a real six-year-old
girl can I be honest it looks like you
sound a good time I was gonna say my
good time you mean it's a disaster thank
you for everything today and she shuts
down the lights and stuff fall asleep on
the couch in your own blanket that's
nice like do they do dudes - I'd like to
do good best friend all that that's
problem I could use a good best friend
who texts me like dude just checking on
you maybe we're working so much lately
robots are going to be and they're like
Brian's annoying right my god thank you
talking about my bad it was bad on you
why didn't I just rush it to the robot
why is it about everybody else
don't go bad a little rank he's like you
little rinse the worst right I'm like
god thank you lil rank don't say little
well ranks robot
he says his name robot youth even have a
name for your best friend your cyber
best friend are your there they're gonna
have robots that look so real and feel
surreal like you really can [ __ ] yeah
100% there we have the dolls now you
there's guys who are in like real ships
with dolls now we've seen this let me
see the most
pensive sextile all right I type in best
sex doll best sex doll mmm definitely
get a virus a computer but yet how about
these two and eight sex doll buyer's
guide holy [ __ ] laughs we can't show
this stuff why discusses that top left
one dude big boobs and butts she would
get one for the studio well I just feel
like dude 70 hundred dollars this deal
for research yes
what the [ __ ] those are real dolls yeah
they're almost four foot seven five feet
dude send these to those [ __ ] mass
shooters they're all lonely and [ __ ]
send a couple of these Horrors true
1,700 the cheap deal you wanna click on
me yeah you know I scroll up to it late
the third one in the third one like I
just do that click on that yeah I bet
you did playboy damn you can pick eyes
skin color dude can you make her black
for me what are the boobs like they look
all kinds of that just change the face
of each when I click on it oh damn came
into vagina - maybe when it's all done
feet that gets a little weird oh this is
crazy
I had no idea a slightly turned on
[ __ ] look at the face down ass up I
mean I have a huge boner look at the you
know what you know upbeat Christmas
coming up bro I would give it a whirl
Zoey you want for Christmas I will order
it right now no I don't want that so
badly I don't exactly dude that's insane
and what house she's the size of a
normal woman 4 foot 7 or 5 feet 1 this
is 5 feet 105 feet 1 is what you want
you want a normal size like incredible
you don't I will do that I'm gonna use
it it's a discount from 20,000 I'm in
2015 I know well let me see some of the
other ones that's a good discount
I say 10% off right now for the holidays
dude who cleans it out though like
obviously counts when we bust in that
thing's mouth
you will I would never dare to her oh my
god this is nuts dude look at the jeans
look at the one in Jean stop you tell
you got a real girl not go back hold on
I want the other one there that no
blonde with the yellow Dubois what's
going on Ryan whatever you like do you
know what that one
there's 11 reviews five foot two well
she's great yeah she's only sixteen
hundred $29 dude for I swear for
Christmas I'll buy this if you'll use it
yeah I use it but you'll be creepy by
use I mean America Brennan I'm not gonna
say what I'm gonna do with it but she'll
be let's put it this way should be well
oiled she'll have a bunch of she'll have
a bunch of rug burns you know that yeah
hopefully that's durable listen oh you
too kiddo a grocer but I want her to be
like a Twinkie look at mill her up likes
this is nuts look at that that's crazy
that's real life yeah I appreciate that
what the [ __ ] dude I mean why go for me
fine hold on here's the thing how's it
coming shipment because if it just looks
like a human body gets delivered to
Brian's house we have some issues gonna
be hard since you have to put it
together like oh I bet shipping ain't
cheap son how about sex doll Helen
please if you don't mind if you don't
mind sex doll Helen would be really
seasick so huh this woman yeah that one
I like I mean if you're gonna get
extreme let's get extreme is it too much
eye makeup there's too much five five
you promised no all you to that other
one let me let me see the other ones the
chain then we'll move on this is nuts
dude this is that ones ridiculous yeah
I'm mad what though well yeah I mean I
would actually I don't I feel like we
should get one for the studio like right
there I think so I do think so dude we
can go halfsies yeah you know everybody
eat you pay for all of it cuz I can't be
seen paying for this but the point is
for the hell of it I think it's great
decoration for this me too dude but we
need her fully clothed so we don't get
sued jeez hold it
that that is insane yeah I mean yet
appreciate [ __ ] techno money buys you
happiness apparently well which one I
don't know what I mean if you want that
one but I guess roat's the most
expensive one catchable so throw it in
as a bonus well this is exile a shirt
with [ __ ] ash is a great name
wow that one boy that one throws you for
a loop doesn't can we decide what size
the dick you know that's just an
impossibly this is a whole nother genre
had no idea about either what if I sent
that to your ass don't think anyone
that's just too much yeah what does go
bad child I didn't see that good eye
chin good eye sir I am outraged well
dude they look so real
I'd like if anyone out there has signed
my dams tell me what it's like I want
look at the far left out to the real
girl dude that's a real girl she's she's
five five nineteen hundred dollars
doesn't talk back nice and dogs worth it
million dollars best investment ever I
mean look at her dad you'd feel like a
real creep though wouldn't you your
house apparently I action click on that
lower right the far bottom right one I
just this one yeah is that a real I mean
yeah let's get all of them let's get a
few let's get a few let's get this kid
the one was that kick for you though
let's get let's get like a few and then
one with the giant [ __ ] with a giant
[ __ ] is sitting there I don't know how
he has started oh homeboys married to
the [ __ ] anime right alright well
this is good okay well now I know those
things are hanging huh
what's going on with mama cow do you
want to breastfeed all the children that
1,900 bucks get the [ __ ] out of here
oh she's gonna roll more two
three-year-olds face look at the [ __ ]
face suchan infants face but she has
some straight-up
oh Jesus Christ you dude did you did you
grab you are you know bombed Pearl
Harbor with those two I mean howitzers
[ __ ] howitzer girl you got such a
deep fade you you've got GRANDMONT
howitzers listen to me
get her out field she belongs I mean
that those are grazing two dozers that's
stupid you can propose like those blue
grapes that I've ever seen in my life
those are offensively long and now I'm
out no I know Jesus Christ those things
I launched a career holy [ __ ] that's
crazy
Kim Jong Un's bad damn did a couple of
[ __ ] nuclear we can end on that I was
having a nice time with this where we
are doing daddy [ __ ] I'm out man that
now got weird right I mean put an older
face on it hey I mean there is such a
thing you much would be it was these
check leads higher by was it too
I mean [ __ ] oh I can man one of her tits
god like you sir [ __ ] one / - oh my god
how's the skiing God Jesus Christ some
of these ridiculous alright let's move
on alright well there it is Wow look at
Patricia I'm not mad not either
Patricia keep scrolling down whew man
there's an ebony it's a ship a big ass
click on Molly
oh wait Molly God yeah click that's her
oh wait no you click - everyone chin I
gave her back my looks a little fake me
too
I just feel like she's a little fake her
face and acid titties are just out of
like not cool fade yeah
let's fake alright let's move on nips
yeah all right better than those [ __ ]
yes
[ __ ] that's crazy all right rampe
titties okay in other news dual pods are
gonna stop selling the flavored little
pods in stores because teens are getting
ahold of it kids are gonna addicted to
it right and they market to kids like
it's like unicorn flavor and [ __ ]
strawberry banana creme brulee they're
trying to because cigarettes are phasing
out no smoke so you get your [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
so now how they're trying to get kids
these same companies are trying to get
kids by these cool flavors and [ __ ]
basic at what cereal did with you know
Trix are for kids and [ __ ] lucky
charms and Cookie Crisp and Captain
Crunch which I love Froot Loops fruity
pebbles do we know how bad vape is
vaping is not good for you
yeah it's all chemicals right it's very
bad for you it's better than cigarettes
but it so far the research has shown
that it's not good no yeah not good some
case have said it's worse than
cigarettes as far as that Howard is on
the
you can't be healthy because this is
much more concentrated than her ettus
really concentrated okay and a lot of
it's mixed with alcohol what yeah like
vaping marijuana or this stuff a lot of
it is the mixes are without call so
you're smoking that what else we got so
Rob Kardashian is pulling a fifty-cent
right now and saying that he's broke so
he can't pay child support China looks
like those dolls were looking at just
identical to one of the dolls gee my god
like dude sent me one that looks a
little more realistic a lot of Botox
face are you've seen her body it's
insane
Chintan says that she looks like page of
ANZAC I've said this to you guys before
there's like a there's like some sort of
a similarity to page nose and eyes but
but page looks like a hundred times
better
she lost be all natural except for today
but you see like a there's a similarity
that I never thought I would imagine I
think it's just the shape of their face
and their features like if page was a
doll maybe whatever you into creepy Rob
Kardashian I feel like has doesn't his
sisters everybody has money but him well
no I'm sure listen his his family you
all everyone's jiggling there's I'm sure
they help him out he's the kid who never
found its way
his father died who was his hero his
other close guy that he was with was
Lamar Odom who lost he's a drug addict
and pieced out on so he's never kind of
found his way and then you have these
sisters who and you were just a horse
and they're making money so you can be
pretty [ __ ] up oh and then your
stepdad who you're kind of close with
goes you know I do don't let your dad
anymore I'm your mom
so he's gone through a lot yeah I guess
he's try starting a sock is hard to find
your bearings right it's hard to kind of
go well I think he's just lost yeah also
the there are rumors that are
speculating that he's only doing this in
order to have blac chyna drop abuse
allegations against him because during
their I believe like the child custody
battle she claimed that he was
physically violent and I he would hit
her but if you watched their reality TV
show that came out for like six months
you see that she's the one who hits him
for sure yeah she would beat him up for
sure
you ever seen our sex tape no no me
neither um I will say this about about
20 grand a month this gonna sound like
shitty to say but in Los Angeles if
you're living that lifestyle $20,000 a
lot of money because it's 240 a year
right a lot of money in Los Angeles it
get it
it gets you exactly almost nothing in
this [ __ ] crazy town right if you
live that if you live that lifestyle
what do mean what lifestyle well I mean
Grande Jodi wicked your rent is you know
or your your mortgage if you even have a
modest house in this town is crazy so
you almost expend more than that well so
so if you how much money do you have to
put down so what I'm saying is that 20
grands $240,000 a month a year in Los
Angeles the way they live just for child
support
yeah I mean just to take care of a baby
no that's a lot babies aren't
delectation oh that's a lot I'm saying
but if that's all she has to live on
which she doesn't she will shoot I'm
saying no in other words she's not rich
is what I'm saying it's not it's a
that's not rich money in Los Angeles
you're you're middle-class in Los
Angeles with that kind of money if
that's all you're getting
do you know just what's rant or if you
try to pay a mortgage it's this town is
[ __ ] crazy expensive it depends how
you live a hundred percent yeah I know
people make less than that and they're
doing pretty good well like I said it's
a lot of money it's just it's it's
amazing how in Los Angeles but again
depends the circles you run in be well
the circles they run in the Kardashians
I'm sure well if she's trying to
maintain a huge mansion in Calabasas
yeah but if she you know I don't I don't
know what even in situations like if you
gonna drive drive the top-of-the-line
Range Rovers twenty five hundred bucks a
month I think she does well for herself
most of her money to what I understand
is based off of Instagram sponsorships
yes pretty well yeah she's pretty
well-known I just don't know if that's
enough to support her type of lifestyle
I mean oh my god fourteen point eight
million
Wow very large following [ __ ] okay
yet the twenty grands just to take care
of that baby looks just like Rob yeah
cute kid
kids can couple good mom I'm not mad at
her she just looked just like those
dolls yeah she's a stripper and then you
know that's super famous kid with her
rumor is she did it out of spite to get
back at Kylie for dating her uh Tyga
yeah her ex yep she's got her priorities
you what else you got you want to talk
about this a little bit yeah a bunch of
celebrities are getting together and
helping out with the fires like the lead
singer of the Foo Fighter stayed back
during evacuations to barbecue for the
firefighters I know Joe Rogan posted
something up about his friend doing the
same yeah cuz I gotta say something cuz
I got a lot of flack for putting on my
Instagram where you can donate a lot of
people in Malibu are not rich in fact a
lot of people in Malibu are there are a
lot of sections in Malibu especially on
the other side of the hill that are not
it's not like these people have a lot
they just don't
they've been been there for 40 years a
lot of working a lot of people I work
with who are working-class people
they've had their houses there for 40
years and they don't have a lot of money
and in fact when their house goes they
don't have options so that's what we're
talking about here we're talking about
helping the firefighters while talking
about helping people with generators
that people have been there forever it's
not them multi millionaires with huge
mansions yes they've lost a lot of
houses too but there are a lot of people
out there who who's giving me flak be I
did the thing that I ba that a lot of
the comments why I don't read comments
the thing or the thing well your posts
are made tough is like your your so you
said donate clothes and stuff there it's
such a limited amount of people in LA
who could do that it'd be better opposed
to link where the entire world could
donate money
you don't say Astra but they need
generators if I was just I was asked to
do that from people who are running the
supply chain mmm I was like all right
you know I said can we use your platform
and apparently some people did so but
yeah I thought about that
yeah it's such a limited yeah I mean if
you're in LA and you can drive here you
know I'm say
I Drive I've been [ __ ] working I want
to drive up there we're in LA it's
that's good they're doing as they're
taking so so my buddy Nathan is taking
supplies from those two spots and they
boat them up to Paradise Cove and then
drive them up so look at that that's
Whitney right yep
she's such an animal lover she's all
bunched up but something happened about
this apparently a giraffe was just fine
yeah
huh but can you do that good thinkin
ruins helping starting at those fires
under control yeah a new one just
sparked up the other day though [ __ ]
different area though yeah close to the
area what else you got you want to talk
about that monica lewinsky docu-series
that's coming on a knee yeah I find this
so interesting man cuz now Monica
Lewinsky says since the me to movement
has happened she's like yeah you know
Bill Clinton was a predator and you know
he came after me and used his power and
I just find it so fascinating I just
like hold on did both of you are guilty
yeah cuz you applied at the White I know
he was married
you knew he was married you decide to
engage in this conduct you wanna have a
relation disclosure you said you loved
him you would suck his dick in the White
House kept the dress when there was a
spot on it interesting to me you're
interesting these women have takes some
responsibility you think but also time
anybody has to have a good time when a
man's in power man or woman especially
when a man's in power yes yes young
attractive women are gonna want to do
them they are attracted to him it's a
power when you are a man in power quote
unquote you're not the enemy
women want to [ __ ] you do you no not
know that take a look at it go to a
fight and you look at all these really
wealthy men there with beautiful women
younger beautiful women it's just the
way it is and by the way a lot of really
powerful women now are dating young hot
dudes it does go both ways but it's
mainly a one-way street
it's I still find it super convenient
and you know she's obviously doing this
the shows coming down there's book tours
all that the rape thing against Bill
Clinton I'm not too
familiar with but this lady says if my
Lewinsky was hurt by her experience with
Bill Clinton can you imagine the pain
and trauma I went through when Bill
Clinton attacked me raped me and left me
injured and bleeding a little Rokit yes
oh yeah there are number different nail
I'm not defending any of that there are
a number of stories around him about him
raping assaulting women what there's
absolutely one of the things was that
because he was such an advocate of
women's rights and abortion and things
like that the liberal left gave him a
free pass and that's a fact that a lot
of liberal the people on the liberal
left have owned up to to their people it
was kind of a deal with the devil
because he was he was he was every bit
as much or more of a of a sexual assault
or as someone like Donald Trump there's
no question about that Wow
and more there were just countless very
credible stories of credible stories and
if it'd been today he would never have
gotten away with it never because too
many women would have been because the
evidence a bunch on it was so
corroborating to it was so [ __ ] it
helps me be if you read it it was so so
believable and all corroborated it was
just you know and by the way the
troopers the the people that would take
him as governor to these hotels they
corroborated the stories it goes on and
on didn't if you really want to ride no
idea bill son just be playing the
saxophone raping [ __ ] he did what he
wanted Jesus he also had a lot of women
I liked him darling
yeah I heard yeah but he definitely did
some [ __ ] wow that's crazy
Kathleen why I'm excited for this series
though Kathleen why earlier when she was
all she caught went to him said I need I
need you to help my husband's husband
her husband was suicidal sign and she in
the and he was holding a tray of tea and
stuff in the White House he gave it to
her to hold and when she was holding it
he started he just attacked her grabbing
her tits and trying to kiss her and and
my mother said to me well the reason I
believe her is you know what she said
when she said it's because the first
thing she said is I thought I was afraid
I was going to spill everything on the
rug my mother said that's exactly what a
woman would think
and I was just I was a freshman she's
all crazy there's just too many stories
about it he's a bad guy huh definitely
with women
yikes what else you got no I had no idea
oh my god it's all you guys know there's
all the Republicans would talk about
when he was on power it was all the
Republicans talk about he unimpeached
yeah and one of the things well that was
all part of the faculty lied under oath
and said that I never had sexual
relations with that woman yeah and then
is if you ever listen to his testimony
with Kenneth Starr it's fascinating
don't guess who one of the lawyers was
on that panel who was who was
formulating questions ooh bread
Cavanaugh oh wow Cavanaugh was part of
that believed he worked with Kenneth
Starr at least partial part of the time
so that's pretty fascinating so blah
blah blah the point is is that he was
truly he was he was I mean there was
just too much evidence but I think it's
interesting the Monica Lewinsky saved
that dress with that spawn on it why'd
she saved that dress everybody has a
motive man everybody has an agenda what
else she is good you know about Le'Veon
Bell right yeah he not reporting and
giving up 14.5 million dollars here's
the thing with labia on bail do you know
about this be so best running back in
the NFL he played for the Pittsburgh
Steelers they want to franchise tag him
again he goes no you owe me a long-term
deal man don't keep franchising because
you franchise I can sign him for 14
million in one year the next year
nothing's guaranteed so he's going no I
want a long-term deal I put him work for
you guys I'm only getting older I
deserve this and they go well no we just
want to franchise tag you for one year
he goes then I'm like in rapport hope
kind of forcing their hand and yeah find
my guy we need you well yep they're like
probably the fourth or fifth best team
in the NFL
his backup Connor I think it's James
Connor from I figure where he's from I
would say Pitt anyways is balling his
backup the guy who goes [ __ ] we're
missing levy on bail see if this kids
any good is balling he's tearing it up
so Pigford Steelers it's kind of it's
backfired on lady on bail because now
he's out 14 million dollars they don't
really want to do a deal with them cuz
like no we're fine we're playing really
good football shirts like okay come up
one thing next year but you know you
you've literally missed out on 14
million dollars
that's a lot of money but this is James
honey next year he'll he'll sign for a
lot of money right hopefully yeah but no
team no one really wanted to trade for
him this year no you know so hopefully
he's so damn good you know but there's a
14 million dollar myth that you know if
they would have if they would have been
like doing okay and that James Connor
the his backup wasn't playing well he
probably got a deal my feeling is that
that's the end of running backs for
whatever reason in this today's game my
feeling is that 14 million dollars is
why they signed you to a franchise
player because running backs seemed to
last so like three years four years so
if you saw a huge thing it's like that's
what the NFL says yeah they're going to
we can't find a six year hundred million
dollar deal because hurt your toe I know
something's gonna break but is that fair
well they're just being business about
it you and I if we were sitting there oh
I love them III we'd have the same
conversation I go what does he want a
hundred million dollars 150 million but
that's why guys are baseball no that's
why guys are being like do this [ __ ]
up cuz if I get hurt like Earl Thomas
for the theok said you wanted a big
contract like no you're getting older he
was come on give me a big contract don't
know yes fine I'll sign this one
one-year deal and then next year
hopefully you guys are usign me like
yeah let's do that hurt you got hurt
right so I don't it's it's so you also
know that yes he's great but they're our
second string and 3rd string guys who
are amazing and if given the chance can
step up especially with a good offense
especially if the offensive scheme is
really good isn't that a lot of it you
got a really good coach and it's favor
toward your game and your talents if it
just sucked for a lazy ass XR label on
bail because it you know he's trying to
do the right thing and hopefully you
know changed the way people look at
these running back stuff like he's only
26 just well at 30 your dinosaur for
good years and they look how many
attempts and catches he's had like he
has a lot of miles on them is what
they're thinking so 20 26 years old by
30 years you're a dinosaur well how long
he's born in the daily and Thomason who
was incredible but again it's like after
three years once they turn 30
over all right what else we got
that's a tough situation oh let's do
this one there's a better article on
this but so robert whittaker 1gq
sportsman of the year robert whittaker
robert whittaker however i don't know
how they split them up in categories of
like Australia or British ones or if
they're all just the one thing for GQ
[ __ ]
I'll look it up right here and that
that's international you said are you
saying four would that be Robert
Whittaker Oh middleweight champion
that's just some hot girl B well that's
Emily ROG which Kowski whatever the
super hot chick she got famous off of
the Robin Thicke music video oh that's
right mhm
Australia's first ever you see champ and
200 G sportsman and so that's got to be
straight up GQ GQ is very surprised what
work has been announced as sports
another year in Sochi others start but
it was held in Australia Australia I
know that um Anthony Joshua won at once
and Lewis Hamilton won at once
either way it's you yes truly it's
[ __ ] enormous that's awesome 20s man
oh yeah they announced his fight against
killing gas lemon Australia's official
yeah he must be
yeah he's Maori he's from New Zealand I
think he's Maori then you talented dude
is insane
what does she get our let's go with this
guy so he was a former bachelor star
Chris soules do you remember this story
like where he did a hit-and-run with a
guy on a tractor no so he long before
the show or after the show I think was
after after you film didn't kill
somebody
yeah so he hit this guy and like a like
a regular tractor going on down the road
and then he stayed with them till the
paramedics arrived and then he took off
so the guy ended up dying later but he's
charged he pleaded he pled guilty and
now he's gonna face up to two years in
jail instead of like what it could have
been life in jail honorable that he
stayed with that's one of the biggest
reasons why he's getting the sentence
lowered he got two years yeah it was an
accident
of course yes and I said yeah you know
what I think maybe the thing was he left
because he was possibly drunk but I'm
not sure if he was actually testing in
was drunk so just one more that quit
that's terrible but it was a hit and run
for sure that ended up in a death what
else yet you had something really cool
here but it's gone now it was a sex
dolls no oh what about this marine vet
gets banned from Disney parks worldwide
because he held a trump sign going down
that why well he did this before
prior to like he put a big old banner on
one of the like either the restaurants
or something in Disneyland
so did it again now he's banned from all
of them who gives a [ __ ] you're not
supposed to story like no one's really
gonna see this except for his followers
when he tweet to post this you know
people also do this all the time on
these rides they do really yeah there
are a bunch of pictures like people who
glue like chess boards pretending like
they're playing it that's what I saw one
i reposted I mean months ago this guy
has Jordans and because you get wet he's
like this with his Jordans going down so
funny interesting this is the last one
so it's just max Holloway Sun so Bruno
Mars was at in Hawaii for a concert and
this is max Holloway son Bruno and uh
max got a picture yeah
Bruno actually blasted it out
[Music]
so I guess he does this all the time
even at UFC's he dances like yeah why is
there no music playing though oh he's so
cute
yeah super cute kid man yeah and there's
him at the EOC dancing again well he
does that little what do you call that
the gap yeah davon super swaggy kid
super look at him oh my god how old is
he
I think what a cutie man so cute always
looked three I love it man that's
adorable age it's such a [ __ ]
adorable age wow that's so jealous of
people in the Heather their kids that
age I missed my son that's not three
right that's the session really for that
might be a Polynesian three yeah he's
gonna be older than three in those
dancing videos yeah at least five I
don't know really yeah for sure
yeah then max Holly was in Bruno Mars's
last I think most recent Instagram posts
so cool man that it that's it man what
do you two got going on this weekend for
get out here Kat usually just working
yep my sister is coming into town for
Thanksgiving
hey was that girl trying some gravy
should I get some dark meat what you
doing what you doing yeah I thought it
was this week - that's next week we get
to a next week's episode
damn what's up bro - we'll be a damn tie
am I [ __ ] hater q dude I am it's a
boring bird a [ __ ] boring bird when
when when you're thinking Thanksgiving
with friends Jen there's a bunch of them
but I was until like two of them already
more than one yeah what are you doing
this weekend um I'm gonna finish that
behind-the-scenes video maybe like
published on Friday to that so there's
that all right kids
well be I'm off to a Sacramento brother
Friday Saturday two shows Friday to show
Saturday early show both freighting said
almost sold out if not already sold out
so get to you through the late shows
Friday Saturday Sacramento punchline
then after that I'm taking my little fix
going to New York little fix in New York
City Gotham comedy club twist a sneeze
and New York City Gotham
comedy club November 30th and through
December first I would be running around
the city I would be at peloton I've
eaten pizza I'll be doing everything the
New Mexico December 7th and 8th and then
just announce Icehouse December 28th
through the 29th Ice House Pasadena the
only other one we haven't announced yet
and it's coming in January right before
my Showtime special the week before I'm
doing I think five or six shows in
Edmonton I love that Edmonton Canada
that will be up any day now so I didn't
think it's your mama right and then the
biggest mall in the world no another
mall it's a big Edmonton get your mind
right
but anyways Sacramento see this Friday
Saturday tief at kake.com
for tickets I think that did be hey
buddy
all righty then this the Vaughn kid
we're out